こんにちは！
「Hajime's Cooking」へ･･･
ようこそー！
はい、というわけで今回の調理師を
務めさせていただきます
・・・・
米
騒動ノ助です
よろしくお願いします
今回調理する料理は
こちら！
ポップコーンです！
皆さんポップコーン
ただただ、あの何か粒を
あの、鍋にぶち込んでこう
パッパパッパやるポンポンなると思ったら
大間違いですよ(謎)
ポップコーンには
無限の楽しみ方があるんです
今回こちらに
バ カ みたいに
まずこちら！
めんたいこマヨネーズ味
頭が
イカれてますね♪
キャラメル味
これはまあ基本的ですね
チョコ味
どうしたんでしょう
テリヤキチキン味
お肉が食べれない僕でも楽しめそうですね！
カレー味
案外いける気がします
チーズ味
ありきたりそうで何か嫌ですね
牛タン塩味
楽しみでしかたがありません！
ブラックペッパー味
特にノーコメントです
コーンポタージュ味
まるでうまい棒のようですね
フレンチドレッシング味
何考えてるかよく分かりません！
というわけで今回はこちらの
10種類のポップコーンの味を準備しました
（クレーマースイッチ作動）
そんな皆さまのために今日は
この
よく分かんねえ味のポップコーン10種類を
ぜ～んぶ混ぜて
不思議な味のポップコーンを作ってみようと
思います♪
（クレーマースイッチ作動）
っしゃあやるでえ！！
ちなみにこれ１つで１人前分の
ポップコーンがあるんで
僕がこれ全部混ぜると
10人前分のポップコーンになってしまいます
食えねえ～
今回ちょっと僕が知りたいのは
どんな味になるか
だって頭おｋ･･･
すごい･･･
クリエイティブじゃないですか
ポップコーンの味なんて普通はあの
いつもの味かなんか
キャラメルぐらいのイメージだったんですけども
こんなたくさん知らねえ味があるなんてもう･･･
びっくり仰天
というわけで早速全部ぶち込んでいきまっしょう！！
うわすげえ、待っ･･･
は、粉？
粉が入ってるんだ
まずは手持ちのついた深い鍋に
コーンがかさらないように並べます
なるほどなるほど
これコーン入れすぎたらよくねえな
焦げちまう！
まあとりあえず程よいレベルに･･･
/ザラザラザラ\
わぁうるさあっ！！
程よいレベルに
コーンを入れて
え、でもこれ結構いけるんじゃね？
全然入るんだけど
/ザアアアア\
これコーンが被らなきゃいいんでまだ入るぜ？
あ、もうやべえかも
/ザアアアア\
もうだめだ
だめ、まじ
/パラパラパラパラ･･･\
これ以上は無理やな
多分これぐらいで丁度いいレベるだっ･･･
/ジャラジャラジャラジャラ\
（調子に乗り始めるはじめ）
ああああああ！！
ふう･･･
/ジャラ\
はあ･･･
ふひひひ･･･
ひ･･･
ひい･･･
作りまぁ～す
でえいっ！
あ、もう･･･忘れ物
（キッチン）
というわけで
キッチンまで来ました
というわけで今からこのポップコーンを
熱で熱するんですけど
その前に！
サラダ油をひいていこうと思いまーす
やばいサラダ油が無い
終わったか
え、ガチで無いじゃん
うわ無いわ
はいというわけでサラダ油を
準備してきました！
これを今からポップコーンの中に
全部ぶち込みます
すいません多分全部入れちゃだめでした
どれぐらいかなぁ･･･
全部浸るくらいだから･･･
うわ入れすぎたかなぁ
まあいっか
全体が浸るくらいで多分大丈夫だとオメース(思います)
これで、フタを･･･
フタあっ！？
フタどこー
えーっとフタ･･･
あとはもうフタをして
ファイヤーすればもうできると思います
いきます！
ファイヤー！
中火ぐらいでいいのかなー
多分これで多分ポンポンなると思います
いやー楽しみやなー
ポップコーンなんてそうそう食わんからなー
映画館なんかなかなか行けへんでホンマ
うわなんかもうグツグツ言ってる
動画的に見えなく･･･うおっ！
待って、はやあっ！
やべえやべえ見えなくなっちゃった
これ多分あれですね
動画的には多分開けた方が良いんだと思います
開けます･･･
ポップコーン「開けれるもんなら開けてみろや」
ポップコーン「どうしたお前」
ポップコーン「怖気づいたか？」
ポップコーン「そうだ、それでこそ男だ」
ポップコーン「やったー自由だー」
ポップコーン「お前は選択を誤った」
待って熱っ！
熱っ！
待って！
油がやばい！油がやばい･･･
待って熱い熱い！
待ってアチチ！
あっつい！
待って！待って！
待って･･･
あ"あ"あ"あ"っ！！
やばい！
ポップコーン「おいはじめ！ここから出せ！」
ポップコーン「一緒に油をひいた仲だろ？」
ポップコーン「開ければきっと良いことがあるぞ！」
F○○k
はーい
というわけで出来ました！
（アイツはもう死んでるよな･･･）
はい、というわけでうわ待ってすげえなー
もう
出来立てほやほやっていうかもう
物量が何かかなりおかしいんですけども･･･
ポップコーン無事、出来ました！
一回ちょっとお皿に移しまーす
やべえや、おせち料理より多いぜ
まあ、多いに越したことはありません
よおっしゃこれを今から･･･
もうちょっと謎の味を混ぜまくって
誰も食べたことのないような
不思議なポップコーンを作ってみたいと
思いますぅー
これどうやって混ぜようかなー
絶対まず粉を混ぜた方が良いんですよね
粉の色でポップコーンの色も決まっていきます
これ多分チョコだな･･･
※早送り
はい、5種類出してみたんですけども
今のところ地面感しかありません
どこの地層なのでしょうか
※早送り
こんな感じになりました
結局粉を全部
こう均等にポップコーンに
まぶせなきゃいけないんで
ふる作業が入ります
いやポップコーンの量が多いので
もう袋にやらざるを得ないので
一回袋に全部移します
っしゃあ！
そんでこのポップコーンの中に
粉を全部入れていきます
おらあっ！
/シャカシャカシャカ･･･\
※早送り
/シャカシャカ\
/釈迦\
うわ、あ、あ･･･
やばいこれ出来てる出来てる
文句なしの100点満点ですわ！
あーやべえやべえやべえ
出来ました！
というわけでこちらが
売っていた全種類のポップコーンを混ぜた
究極のポップコーンでございます
何か思った以上にうまくいったんで
ちょっと僕もびっくり仰天してるんですけども
大事なのは味です
こっからが大事なんです
いや僕はもう全力を尽くしました
油でやけどをしながら
完成させた至極の一品でございます
どんな味がするんでしょうか･･･
ちょまず匂い
何だ、ダメだ混沌としすぎててちょっと
よく分かんない
いただきます
待ってなんだこれ
なんだこれ
え？分かんない
※早送り
え？
うめえ！なんだこれ止まんねえ･･･
※早送り
5人前食べても味がうまく表現できませんが
口いっぱいに含みたくなる
チーズ･･･カレー･･･テリヤキ･･･ピザっぽい味が
ベースにあって
でその周りをなんかすごい
甘い味がコーティングされてるというか
なんかもう
飽きないし
うまい！
え、うまっ！これマジで･･･
うあ、もう、やばもう止まんないっしょ
はい、というわけで何かすげえ
クセになる味でした･･･
【ED】